we know that this turned out to be quite
a large-scale file that fire that took
place at the new County hotel in Perth
just at about 10 past five this morning
police confirming some of the details
within the last hour or so we know
there's a huge emergency service
response you can see from the video that
we now have
showing you now of the the scale of the
Blaze and how ferociously this took hold
around 21 ambulance crews in attendance
around nine fire trucks in the end had
to be sent to put out this fire it has
now been extinguished confirmation
within the last hour certainly from the
police that sadly there have been three
deaths as a result of what happened here
this morning this is a reasonably small
hotel about 28 bedrooms
um not that far away from the center of
Perth a number of people had to be
treated for minor injuries as a result
of what happened we know that guests and
two people from a neighboring block of
flats they also had to be evacuated very
quickly from the premises to ensure that
more people weren't injured injured as a
result of what happened and we've had a
statement through from the chief
superintendent of police Scotland Phil
Davidson who said our thoughts are very
much with the families and loved ones of
those who have died what is very a very
difficult time for everyone our
inquiries are ongoing to establish the
full circumstances of what has happened
and officers are conducting a joint
investigation with the Scottish fire and
rescue service
Scotland's Deputy first Minister John
Swinney is also tweeted he's of course
the MSP for perthshire north and he said
that it's heartbreaking news that's
emerging this morning and he's sent his
sympathies to all those who've been
affected by what happened we know that
members of the public are being told not
to go to this area because certainly the
roads in the surrounding areas have now
been closed off as the fire service
investigate exactly what what happened
here and what might have caused these
these deaths and what caused the fire
itself but yes certainly a huge
emergency response has been sent to that
area as a result of this fire that broke
out in the early hours of the morning